-It is so good to see you, bud.
Congrats on the book.
-Thanks so much.
-Number one. Not too shabby.
-Not bad, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can't get better than that.
-So happy. Very lucky.
-Yeah, I wanted to talk to you,
because it's been such a --
It's been an awful year.
-I know.
Honestly, I just --
So much has happened, and it's
been so rough for everybody.
And you look back,
and you're like, "The pandemic?"
How long has it been?
I have no clue now.
We say a year, but what is it?
Like 18 months now. And I'm just
honestly happy to be here.
I'm so -- I just feel so good.
I'm ready for
this next year ahead.
-Let's do it.
We're going to get there.
-Yeah.
-I saw an interview -- Or
I read an interview, actually.
You were talking about this book
and how this one
is very personal.
-Yes. Oh, my goodness.
-You know I love the cookbooks.
I love the other two. I love --
The photography is fantastic.
-Thank you. Yes. Alex.
-Nails it.
-Alex is an incredible
photographer.
-This is the worst way
to hold the book. Sorry.
"I love the photographer."
-I wanted everything to be so
joyful and vibrant and bright.
And I was like,
"This is -- It's a must."
I want it to be colorful
and fun, I want the recipes
to be comforting for people, and
it's everything that we needed
in the time that we wrote it.
-Food is always there for us.
-Yes, it is.
-No matter what we go through.
-It's the one constant.
-It really is.
It's the one thing.
And you go -- You know,
and if it's comfort food,
it's comfort food.
If it's mac and cheese,
it's mac and cheese.
-This is all, like, food
to eat on the couch, basically.
-Yes! That's what we want!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's all I want.
-Is there one ingredient
that we'll never see
in a Chrissy Teigen cookbook?
-Well, this is the issue.
Because I obviously
have to create for everybody.
So I'm like, "Ugh.
Other people like things."
I have to put it in there,
but I genuinely think, like,
if the devil had a garden,
he would grow beets.
[ Scattered applause ]
-No! It's a divided audience.
Really?
-It was a divided audience.
Like, golden beets are good.
So I have a recipe
where I use golden ones.
But they need to be really
sugared up and everything.
The red ones
are just, like, vile.
Vile! I don't know.
They taste like dirt.
-I don't think my wife
likes beets, either.
-Yeah, they're bad.
-I like beets.
-I don't think they're supposed
to be eaten, honestly.
Really?
-Yeah! Like, pickled beets.
-I heard you don't like
mayonnaise, either.
So that is -- And I think mayo
is the binder of all things.
-Mayonnaise is --
Even the name is --
-Oh, I go to Subway,
I'm like, "Extra mayo."
Extra "mayonnaise."
-Oh, no, they changed the name.
They try to make it young
like, "Hey, we're mayo."
You're like, "Hey."
Just call yourself Meta.
It's fine. We get it.
-It's so good!
[ Laughter ]
Metanaise.
-Metanaise. You'll see.
It's going to come out like,
"Oh, we're aioli.
We're traveled."
Like, oh, please.
-I know!
I won't do "french fries
in the mayo" thing.
But mayo -- I feel like
it binds the flavors of things.
I'm gonna get you to like it.
-I know. I can grow out of it.
I went to a wedding once,
and I was just so hungry,
and it was one of
the longest services ever.
And I'm --
You know, I grew up Catholic.
There were, like,
extra steps in this wedding.
I was,
"I never heard of this step."
I'm like -- I was so hungry.
And we got to the reception.
We had to get in a bus
to go to the reception,
up a hill and all this stuff.
I go, "I already
put in the work, man."
And I get there, and they go,
"French fries."
I go, "Oh, my God, yes!"
And they came in a cone
with mayonnaise on the bottom.
-No!
-Pre-dipped and soaked
in mayonnaise?
Well, don't you hate
when you go to a wedding --
-We're never invited
to weddings.
I think people assume
that we can't go,
so we really don't get
very many invites.
-Really?
I don't want to go anymore.
-No, I love --
I like them a lot.
-You do?
-Yeah, I do.
But then there's always like,
"Oh, my, there just
happens to be a piano."
And then you're like...
-"Ah, John, yeah.
You know, can you...?"
-Yes. Every time. Yeah.
"That's so crazy."
-"That's so weird
that there's a piano here
on the back of this bus.
Why would a piano...?
John, do you want
to play maybe one?"
[ Laughter ]
Halloween's this weekend.
Since you're a mom
and a cookbook author,
your opinion on this
is very, very important
to the world right now.
How do you feel
about candy corn?
-Oh, no. Okay, I -- Okay.
-Here we go. Tell me.
-I saw a tweet.
You know, people on Twitter
love to be mad at candy corn,
and I had typed out a tweet
where I said,
"I don't know, guys.
I kind of like it."
And when I say "kind of,"
I really like candy corn.
-You really like candy corn?
-I had typed this out, and then
I was like, "I can't say this.
It's too controversial."
Like, it really is.
Of all the things I've done.
And I'm like, "No!"
-You didn't send it out?
The audience
seems to be with you.
-Do you guys like candy corn?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it tastes like
a buttery Mrs. Butterworth.
Like, to me, it tastes
like a delicious syrup,
and I bite the white tip off
and --
Do you think there's
different flavors? No.
-I try to imagine that there
are, but, no, they're not.
No, right? No, they're all --
All three colors are
just three -- the same.
-White, yellow, and orange.
-It's just candle wax,
candle wax, candle wax.
-No!
-Yes!
-No, it's good.
And the pumpkin-shaped ones?
Do you like those ones?
They're so good!
-I feel like the pumpkin-shaped
ones are candy corns
that went to
Witness Protection Program.
"We're not candy corns.
We're pumpkins."
-"We'll change the shape."
-Yeah, exactly.
Here's what I like
about the book.
Because not only
is it great recipes
and I know it comes from love
and I know
you actually make these,
but there's also a bonus recipe
at the end after, like,
all the credits --
like a Marvel movie.
You finish the movie,
and then it's like,
"Oh, here's your Easter egg."
And then there's another
little bonus recipe there.
Now, what is this one?
-This is essentially --
Well, I love even numbers.
I had an odd number of recipes
in the book.
And then I figured marijuana
has been legalized
in so many states,
so why not just give something
for the high people?
-Okay. All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Can you explain what it is?
-This is essentially Gardetto's
tossed in butter
stuffed into a pita.
-So it's basically like
Chex Mix in a pita?
-Yeah, it's some
buttered Gardetto's.
-All right.
So you put some butter in there?
-Yeah.
-All right.
Let's try this together.
Good luck, buddy.
Happy Halloween.
-This is not what the book is --
The book is real recipes.
-Oh, no. Legit.
But I just thought
it would be funny to eat this.
-Cheers.
-Congratulations on number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not bad. Not bad.
A little dry.
-Not bad. I like it.
-"Cravings: All together"
is available now.
When we come back...
Chrissy and I...
are going head-to-head
in a game of "Pup Quiz."